Part of the reason that Islam has its
backup with regards to the west to such a
degree.
I mean there's many reasons
that not all of them are valid,
that's for sure.
But one of the reasons is that,
you know,
they,
they being still grounded in a,
in a,
in a dream,
let's say,
they can see that the root less
questioning mind of the west pope poses a
tremendous danger to the
integrity of their culture now.
And it does,
I mean Westerners,
us,
we undermine ourselves all the
time with our searching intellect.
And I'm not complaining about Pat.
You know what I mean?
It,
it,
there isn't anything easy
that can be done about it,
about,
but it's still,
it's still sort of fruitful
catastrophe and you know,
it has real effects on people's lives.
It's not some abstract thing.